bonjour mon nom et mot de laillé j'ai 23
ans et dans deux semaines et demie ça va
être mon premier anniversaire de
renaissance et pourquoi j'emploie le
terme renaissance et que le 11 juin 2013
en fait c'est comme si je m'étais fait
faire une remise à neuf parce que j'ai
eu une greffe de moelle osseuse
mon système précédent est complètement
détruit pour faire place à un mât
nouvelle moelle et 7 mois là je devais
l'avoir parce que justement c'était le
traitement ultime dans le but de accéder
à leurs émissions contre le cancer
donc on réagit comment quand on apprend
qu'on a eu le cancer
je pense que chaque personne sur cette
terre ou avoir une réaction qui est très
différente dans mon cas je les a pris en
décembre 2012
ça faisait des mois vraiment des mois
que je me sentais pas bien je me sentais
plus - htt nouveau physique qu'au niveau
de jeu mais ma personnalité jetez plus
la même personne puis c'est difficile de
constater beaucoup de changements puis
de vivre dans l'ambiguïté sans savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe avec toi puis
moment donné tu viens au stade qu'à
penser que c'est peut-être à cause de
toi c'était comme ça t'es fait quand
j'ai appris à 6 heures du matin le 1er
décembre 2012 dans la civière à l'unité
d'évaluation l'urgence que jamais le
cancer sans savoir exactement le
diagnostic formel sur le coup ça a été
un peu un soulagement de savoir que
c'était pas dans ma tête et qui se
passait réellement quelque chose qui
j'ai pas réfléchi tout de suite je me
disais bon départ fait d'accord si c'est
quoi bein ouai fond son jeu s'est passé
j'ai gelé eu le choc quand j'ai dû
appeler mon copain qui était retourné
s'est couché
cette nuit là vers 2 heures du matin je
l'appelle par six heures j annonce sa
nouvelle conjointe que j'ai j'ai comme
réalisé que le cancer pour venir me
rejoindre à l'hôpital et la presse que
je savais que ma famille s'en venait non
mon frère ma soeur mes parents et je
savais pas comment leur annoncer je
voulais pas je voulais je voulais pas
voir leur réaction parce qu'un peu leur
direction c'est une forme ce que la
réalité finalement ça ça voulait dire
que c'est vrai j'avais le cancer fait ce
qui est arrivé c'est que ces mêmes pour
moi qui ai eu à l'heure annoncée puis
pour la simple et bonne raison que quand
c'est arrivé j'étais parti faire pipi
puis c'était mon copain inquiété lors ça
n'était pas parler mais ça a donné que
yo a annoncé la nouvelle à ma famille
celle quand je suis sorti j'ai vu qu'il
était au courant puis ça m'a fait du
bien de savoir que j'ai pu à leur
annoncer directement cette nouvelle là
et l'autre chose c'est juste cette
journée-là particulièrement ce qui était
spécial c'est qu'on célébrer notre
premier adversaire de couple salage
enfin tu veux mon design hyper fin dans
une ville mais la vie telle que je la
connaissais j'ai réalisé qu'elle ne
changeait à partir du moment où parce
que je suis passé l'unité d'évaluation
et que j'ai été amené à les tâches dans
une chambre tout était devenu différent
à ce partir de ce moment là au début
j'étais en chambre double en occupation
d'auby je t'aime motivé le j'avais le
goût de me dois te battre pis j'avais le
goût de faire monter peut-être tout le
monde qui voulait l'entendre qu'on
dirait que je voulais entraîner tout le
monde qui était dans la même situation
avec moi puis ce qui m'a frappé moment
donné c'est la dame qui était à côté de
moi qui me faisais des traitements de
chimiothérapie
elle était hospitalisée parce que ces
traitements lui allait vraiment pas la
raison pour laquelle il faisait des
traitements c'était pas dans le but de
s'en aller en rémission parce qu'elle
savait que c'est incurable
c'est simplement dans le but de
prolonger sa vie sauf que ces
traitements lui donnait une qualité de
vie qui était minable tu y étais au
point de se demander est-ce qu'à
continue ou à l'art est fait là j'ai
réalisé que ça même
j'avais pas fait mon peuple inquiétez
vous pas le même sans même avoir une
mauvaise intention
mes paroles pouvaient la blesser pouvait
avoir un effet vraiment pas comme je
l'espérais c'est là que j'ai réalisé que
les mots avaient une portée puis avait
un certain poids puis dans l'eau par
parle de barjavel adam qui est à côté de
moi mais après ça pour me divertir
jallet sur les réseaux sociaux
et là je vois la personne qui est en
train de qui vit la fin du monde parce
qu'elle est la grippe le on dirait que
mes perceptions ça fonctionne pas le
mois il ya la madame est la personne qui
vit la fin du monde parce qu'elle est la
grippe pilot je suis plus quoi penser
c'est à partir de ce moment là qu'ils
réalisent que ta vie est vraiment pu
paraît comme un vampire je peux
comprendre aussi pourquoi les gens qui
se sentent seuls dans ce genre de
situation là parce que toutes tes
repères comme disait la vie telle que tu
la connais fait pitel que les autres
personnes autour de toi la connaissent
c'est juste ces deux réalités qui sont
complètement différentes puis sachez
qu'elle soit parce que j'ai eu le cancer
que j'aime savoir une gastro que je
trouve ça le fun je livre quelques mois
puis je peux plus c'est monsieur cavale
fait qu en constatant que j'ai réalisé
que oui je te donne lorsque je vivais
mais je n'étais pas seul autour de moi
puis ça devait se passer en équipe je
pouvais pas rester seul là-dedans
pendant d'equipe quand ça va pas faut
que tu dises que tu deviens un capitaine
juste te dire que tu deviens capitaine
sais pas mais moi ça me donne le goût de
me replacer les épaules le juste le le
statut l'on me semble même ceux qui à
partir de ce moment l'homme quand il
devient capitaine tu peux pas rester
seul parce qu'un capitaine tous te
savons pas grand chose ça juste plaindre
idéologie mais ça c'est pas qu'ils le
transmettent cette foutue bâti son
équipe puis c'est pourquoi tu bâtis
cette équipe là tu veux des gens qui
vont traverser toutes les épreuves avec
toi pour ta mener vers la victoire
c'est comme ça qui doit structurer ton
équipe comme dans n'importe quel sport
chaque rôle est important peu importe si
le petit oui et grands chaque rôle sa
place puis quand ça va pas bien
puis que la situation devient instable
ton équipe tu deviens d'instabilité fait
que c'est comme ça que tu réussi à les
rechercher certain équilibre qui
manquent à ta vie dans ce genre de
situation là qui est assez drastiques
d'où l'importance de choisir
judicieusement les membres de son équipe
qui moi j'ai eu un cadeau du ciel
en plus d'avoir une équipe formidable
autour de moi je me suis ramassé avec
une armée sur les réseaux sociaux
j'avais pas prévu ça puis honnêtement je
pense que ça a été la plus belle chose
qui me soit arrivée parce que de segi
tous ces gens là qui étaient derrière
moi chanter leur énergie qui quand est
au front de bataille tête en avant pis
dont activié comme un peu chicken les
gens molto goût de recul et de tout ce
monde est derrière toi que eux ils
veulent se battre qu'ils veulent gagner
ils sont prêts à se rendre leur fait
même si un coup de reculer si tu fais
pousser à avancer malgré toi avec ta pas
le choix d'avancer ce pour moi encore en
regardant ça c'est c'est clair que 1 en
levant de l'équation la partie des
traitements et qui est très importante
en ayant choisi de m'entourer avec plein
de gens et en plus avoir eu toute cette
armée là derrière moi versus avoir
choisi de m'isoler demeurer ferme un peu
comme une huître au début j'avais pas
mal plus de chance de m'en sortir
en utilisant l'énergie des autres pour
me faire avancer
puis au-delà de ça quand j'étais plus
jeune mon père a toujours fait beaucoup
de dons je comprenais pas pourquoi il
faisait ça tout ce que j'ai remarqué s
étaient plaints de calpe une note avec
son nom dessus on devait recevoir des
cales de cartes de noël vierge
différents organismes à tous les années
mais je comprenais pas pourquoi ils
faisaient sopi sept ans avant que moi
j'ai le cancer sont pas mon grand père a
eu le cancer puis mon père m'expliquer
là sens que ça l'avait
pour lui d'avoir fait des dons entre
autres pour la recherche contre le
cancer
quand son propre père a eu un cancer
parce que tu dis mon dieu je contente
d'avoir contribué ça ça donne un sens un
peu à tout sauter puis moi même quand
j'étais malade
malgré la situation difficile j'ai eu
des conditions exceptionnelles j'ai été
dans des très bons centres hospitaliers
j'ai eu des traitements qui était quand
même très avancées je t'ai pas j'ai pas
eu à jouer à son voeux aux cobayes
mais pourquoi parce que il ya des gens
avant moi il ya des gens devant moi qui
ont passé par le ya des gens qui ont
décidé de donner de l'argent qui ont
contribué en étant bénévole en donnant
de leur temps personnel la grève
classique comme moi j'ai reçu ça fait 30
ans que si elle n'existait qu'à ses
débuts des gens qui se sont risqués à
cesser mais pas à s'essayer mais à
mettre leur crosse sur le au profit de
la recherche puis ça fait en sorte que
moi j'ai bénéficié de ce genre de
traitement la fête quand je repense à
tout ça marie mission complète je la
dois pas juste à mon équipe de médecins
ou à ma famille à mes proches à mes amis
même à mon armée qui me suis dit je la
dois à tous ceux qui croient en notre
communauté en notre société parce que
ultime en les conditions dans lesquelles
j'étais c'est grâce à tous ces gens là
parce que demain en tous ceux qui
croient à aider leur prochain parce que
c'est quoi bâtir une société quand ce
bâti une société c'est que tu met en
place des mesures des choses pour rendre
la vie des gens que tu connais pas
meilleure puis je me suis un moment
donné senti très touché parce qu'à un
certain moment dans ma vie est encore
aujourd'hui c'est finalement la victoire
je la dois à tous les autres sans que
vous le sachiez fait que j'aimerais
vraiment vous remercier du fond du coeur